From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，《美国生活》节目，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
We went through a long stretch of time with a lot of open wounds on our hands, so-- and I do remember a lot of times after a game we'd have practice the next morning and we would have to figure out a way to get our glove on because our wounds were wide open. The sweat would actually get into our wounds and burn.
我们经历过很长一段时间，手上满是伤口，所以我记得很多次比赛结束后，第二天早上还得训练，我们必须想办法戴上手套，因为我们的伤口都裂开了。汗水会渗进伤口，引起阵阵刺痛。
Hockey's changed over the years. Joe Kocur is from the days back when there were enforcers, guys whose job it was to get their hands bloody. Joe played for the Detroit Red Wings and the New York Rangers. If you don't know much about hockey, when fights erupt, it can just seem like thuggery, disorganized mayhem. But Joe says that when he would start a fight, it was anything but random. It wasn't arbitrary. Far from it. He was the law.
冰球运动这些年来发生了变化。乔·科库尔（Joe Kocur）来自那个还有“执法者”的时代，他们的工作就是让自己的双手沾满鲜血。乔曾效力于底特律红翼队和纽约游骑兵队。如果你对冰球了解不多，当冲突爆发时，这看起来就像是暴徒行为，是一团混乱。但乔说，当他发起争斗时，那绝非随意的，也并非一时冲动。远非如此。他就是法律。
If a guy runs your goal tender, if a guy runs your best hockey player on your team, he just did a dirty check on a friend of yours, I mean, anything that is not legal in the game and the referee may not see it, and even if the referee sees it, sometimes you have to take it into your own hands to make sure this gentleman doesn't want to do it again.
如果有人冲撞了你们的守门员，或者冲撞了你们队里最好的球员，又或者他对你的朋友进行了恶意的阻截——我是说，任何在比赛中不合法的行为，而裁判可能没看到，即使裁判看到了，有时你也必须亲自动手，确保这位先生以后不敢再这么做。
Let me ask you to give an example of how this goes down. You tell a story in your book about going after Jim Kyte in one game. What did Jim Kyte do?
我请你举个例子说说这是怎么发生的。你在书里讲了一个关于在某场比赛中找吉姆·凯特（Jim Kyte）麻烦的故事。吉姆·凯特做了什么？
Well, throughout the whole game, Jim Kyte was running our captain Steve Yzerman and playing, I call it dirty. He was slashing him a lot and hitting him with the stick, so I was on the ice with about three minutes left in the game. I was a young guy and Jim Kyte was on the ice and was ready to face off.
整场比赛，吉姆·凯特一直在冲撞我们的队长史蒂夫·伊泽尔曼（Steve Yzerman），而且动作很脏，我称之为肮脏的比赛。他经常挥杆砍人，用球杆打他。所以在比赛还剩三分钟左右时，我上场了。我那时很年轻，吉姆·凯特也在冰上，准备开球。
And I went over to one of our veteran defenseman, Mike O'Connell and I said, "Mike, did Coach just put me out here to go after Jim Kyte?" And he said, "Joe," he says, "I don't know your job and I don't know what the coach was thinking but you know what your job is. Do what you think's right." And when the puck dropped, I went after him.
我走到我们的一位老将后卫迈克·奥康奈尔（Mike O'Connell）身边说：“迈克，教练派我上场是为了去对付吉姆·凯特吗？”他说：“乔，我不知道你的任务，也不知道教练在想什么，但你知道你的职责是什么。做你认为正确的事。”当球掉落时，我就冲着他去了。
Now we've got a fight, Kyte and Kocur. And Kocur [UNINTELLIGIBLE] Jimmy Kyte.
现在打起来了，凯特和科库尔。科库尔[听不清]吉米·凯特。
I happened to catch him with a couple pretty good ones and that ended the night. I was scared when I hit him, because I'd hit him so hard and his head had hit the ice and I was worried that he may have been hurt permanently or something.
我正好结结实实地给了他几拳，那天晚上就此结束了。当我打中他时，我感到很害怕，因为我打得太重了，他的头撞在了冰面上，我担心他可能会造成永久性伤害之类的。
Not a pretty sight, but Jimmy Kyte's a tough guy and he's getting up.
场面不太好看，但吉米·凯特是个硬汉，他站起来了。
Now, sometimes somebody did something during the game that would deserve retaliation, would deserve enforcing, but other stuff needed to happen during the game. The clock was running down. You didn't have time to get into a fight, and so you would kind of file that away in your head and wait until you saw them on the ice the next time. Would they know they had it coming?
有时候，某人在比赛中做了什么值得报复、值得“执法”的事情，但有些事情需要在比赛期间处理。时间一分一秒过去，你没时间去打架，所以你会把它记在脑子里，等着下一次在冰上见到他们。他们会知道自己要倒霉了吗？
I think for the most part. Sometimes you didn't go after him right away, because it changed him as a hockey player. He's looking around. He's looking over his shoulder, worried about getting what's going to happen to him, and you may wait a game or two and let him just be on the ice and be unsure of what's going on.
我想大部分情况下是这样。有时你不会立刻冲过去，因为这会改变他的打球方式。他会四处张望，回头看，担心接下来会发生什么。你可能会等上一两场比赛，让他就在冰上，但不确定会发生什么。
I think one of the keys to being an enforcer and intimidating other players is the unknown. If somebody did something to one of our players and you didn't get him that night, you knew he was going to have an uneasy sleep before the next game, and probably for the rest of the year for that matter.
我认为成为执法者并震慑其他球员的关键之一就是“未知”。如果有人对我们的一名球员做了什么，而你当晚没能报复他，那么他知道在下场比赛前，甚至很可能在接下来的一年里，他都睡不好觉。
What's interesting is that the game has referees who are there to keep order, but the refs can only do so much. Kocur says that when a player acts up, the penalties that the ref gives-- two minutes in the penalty box, a $500 fine-- players shrug that stuff off. Who cares? It doesn't change their behavior.
有趣的是，比赛有裁判在场维持秩序，但裁判能做的毕竟有限。科库尔说，当球员闹事时，裁判给出的处罚——罚进禁闭室两分钟，罚款500美元——球员们对此根本不在乎。谁在乎呢？这并不能改变他们的行为。
But if there's an enforcer out there and they know there's going to be some physical pain inflicted upon them for what they did, they're going to have second thoughts about doing it.
但如果场上有个执法者，他们知道因为自己的所作所为会受到肉体上的痛苦，他们再做这些事时就会三思而后行。
At the two political conventions this summer, some commentators started comparing our nation's two vice presidential candidates to hockey enforcers. A guy in The National Ledger wrote, "Barack Obama evidently believes he needs somebody to protect him like a hockey team star, so he chose Senator Joe Biden." A reporter for the Rocky Mountain News wrote, "She calls herself a hockey mom, but now Alaska Governor Sarah Palin is jumping into a job more akin to a hockey enforcer for Senator John McCain. Almost immediately she came out swinging, going straight for Democratic Senator Barack Obama's ribs and knee caps."
今年夏天在两场政党大会上，一些评论员开始将我国的两名副总统候选人比作冰球执法者。《国家分类账》的一位作者写道：“奥巴马显然认为他需要有人像保护冰球队球星一样保护他，所以他选择了乔·拜登参议员。”《落基山新闻》的一位记者写道：“她自称是冰球妈妈，但现在阿拉斯加州州长萨拉·佩林正在承担一份类似于为约翰·麦凯恩参议员担任冰球执法者的工作。她几乎立刻就发起了攻击，直接冲着民主党参议员巴拉克·奥巴马的肋骨和膝盖去了。”
I think what's going on is that our politics are so rough and nobody is really refereeing that somebody's got to be the tough guy, not to bring justice exactly, but to protect their own side. Though, of course, the line between protecting your side and just being a bully can get kind of hazy.
我认为发生这种情况是因为我们的政治竞争非常激烈，而且没有人真正进行裁判，所以必须有人扮演硬汉的角色，不是为了实现确切的正义，而是为了保护自己的一方。当然，保护自己一方和单纯欺凌弱小之间的界限可能会变得有点模糊。
And so, today on our show, Enforcers, people who take the law into their own hands. And also, the people who are supposed to wear the sheriff's badge but sometimes have a hard time putting it on.
所以，今天我们的节目主题是“执法者”，那些把法律掌握在自己手中人。还有那些本该戴上治安官徽章，但有时却很难戴上的人。
Our show in two acts today. Act One, Hanging in Chad. In that act, some freelance self-appointed enforcers who enjoy the hell out of enforcing frontier justice on the internet. Act Two, Now You SEC Me, Now You Don't. Alex Blumberg has the story of an enforcer who refused to enforce even when pleaded with to do more to protect people from the financial turmoil that we see in the news every day. Stay with us.
我们今天的节目分两幕。第一幕，《悬在乍得》。在这一幕中，一些自由职业的自封执法者，他们非常享受在互联网上执行边境正义的快感。第二幕，《SEC见》。亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）讲述了一个执法者的故事，尽管有人恳求他采取更多措施来保护人们免受新闻中每天看到的金融动荡的影响，但他却拒绝执行。请继续收听。
Act One, Hanging in Chad. Like everybody else who has email, I've gotten those messages where they say that there is $8 million sitting in a bank in Nigeria and the money is just sitting there, doing nothing. And somebody needs help getting that money out of the country.
第一幕，《悬在乍得》。像其他有邮箱的人一样，我也收到过那些消息，说是尼日利亚的一家银行里有800万美元，钱就放在那儿，什么也没做。有人需要帮助把这笔钱弄出这个国家。
But until recently when somebody explained it to me, I never really stopped to think about how this scam actually works. If you reply to those emails, after some back and forth, they'll let you know there's a processing fee that you're going to need to pay for the courier, or the insurance, or whatever. And after you pay that, of course, they don't deliver the money. There will be some problem, some bank official who needs to be bribed or some new fee. And they're very sorry. They're sure if you just do this one more thing, you'll get your money. And so you pay that and then on and on it goes. They string you along for as long as they can.
但直到最近有人向我解释时，我才真正停下来思考这个骗局到底是如何运作的。如果你回复了这些邮件，经过一番往来，他们会让你知道你需要支付一笔手续费，用来支付快递费、保险费或其他费用。当然，在你支付之后，他们并不会把钱给你。会出现一些问题，比如需要贿赂某位银行官员，或者出现某种新费用。他们会非常抱歉。他们确信，只要你再做这一件事，你就能拿到钱了。于是你支付了这笔钱，然后没完没了。他们会尽可能地拖住你。
In 2007, Americans reported losing $15 million to this particular email scam. And the real number may be more like a $100 million, according to the federal government's Internet Crime Complaint Center, which says that the average loss to each victim is about $2,000.
2007年，美国人报告称因这种电子邮件骗局损失了1500万美元。据联邦政府的互联网犯罪投诉中心称，真实数字可能高达1亿美元，该中心表示每位受害者的平均损失约为2000美元。
Though, and here's the reason why I'm bringing all this up, it is rare for anybody to be arrested for this. The thieves are hard to catch because, it turns out, they really are overseas in places that American law enforcement has a hard time reaching. Lots of them are actually in Nigeria, so many that one nickname for this kind of con is to call it a 4-1-9 scam. 4-1-9 is the part of the Nigerian criminal code that deals with fraud.
不过，我之所以提起这些，是因为很少有人因此被捕。窃贼很难抓到，因为事实证明，他们确实身处海外，身处美国执法部门难以触及的地方。其中许多人实际上在尼日利亚，以至于这种诈骗的一个绰号是“4-1-9骗局”。4-1-9是尼日利亚刑法中处理欺诈行为的条款。
So into this breach, onto this lawless frontier, where traditional police work has failed, has stepped the vigilantes. Internet vigilantes. The proud. The brave.
于是，在这个传统的警察工作已经失败的无法无天的边境，治安维持者挺身而出。互联网治安维持者。那些骄傲的人。勇敢的人。
I live in the Midwest. I'm a 42-year-old software engineer. I've got four children.
我住在中西部。我是一名42岁的软件工程师。我有四个孩子。
I will identify this man and his friends only with their nom de guerre. His is YeaWhatever and he ran the vigilante action I'm going to tell you about today alongside two of his friends. Jojo, someone below the Mason Dixon line.
我只会用代号来称呼这个人及其朋友。他的代号是“管他呢”（YeaWhatever），他与两个朋友一起发起了我要告诉你们的这次治安行动。乔乔（Jojo），一个梅森-迪克森线以南的人。
Yeah, I'm early 20s, single. I am an engineer.
是的，我20岁出头，单身。我是一名工程师。
And there's Professor So And So out in a Western state.
还有一位是在西部某州的“某某教授”（Professor So And So）。
I'm 31 years old and I have a four-year-old daughter.
我31岁，有一个四岁的女儿。
Three of these guys met on the discussion boards of a website called 419eater.com. That 4-1-9 in the name, yes, refers to the Nigerian criminal code. This is the website where internet vigilantes like themselves compare stories, and share victories, and swap trade secrets on how to get the email scammers.
这三个人是在一个名为419eater.com的网站的讨论版上认识的。名字里的4-1-9，没错，指的就是尼日利亚刑法。这是一个像他们这样的互联网治安维持者比较故事、分享胜利、交换如何对付电子邮件骗子的行业秘密的网站。
And this spring and summer, these three guys ran an operation against the scammers that not only exceeded all expectations, they became kind of an internet sensation in their community, scoring more page views than anything comparable. But it also raised some interesting questions about whether these internet vigilantes, these self-appointed enforcers, go too far.
今年春夏，这三个人针对骗子进行了一次行动，不仅超出了所有预期，还成为他们社区里的一种互联网轰动事件，获得的页面浏览量比任何类似的行动都要多。但也引发了一些有趣的问题：这些互联网治安维持者，这些自封的执法者，是不是做得太过分了？
Chances are you may have heard of guys who do this. They've been around for a while. They call themselves baiters, or scam baiters, because they bait the con men into doing all kinds of ridiculous things. They convince them to get funny tattoos or build pyramids out of sandbags or pose for embarrassing photos.
你可能听说过做这种事的人。他们存在已经有一段时间了。他们自称“诱饵者”或“诈骗诱饵者”，因为他们诱导骗子做出各种荒谬的事情。他们说服骗子纹上滑稽的纹身，用沙袋堆成金字塔，或者摆出令人尴尬的照片。
On YouTube, you can watch some West African email scammers perform on video an old Monty Python sketch about a dead parrot. They had been told over email that they could get a pile of money, a scholarship grant, if they were any good.
在YouTube上，你可以看到一些西非电子邮件骗子在视频中表演一段关于死鹦鹉的蒙提·派森（Monty Python）经典短剧。他们通过电子邮件被告知，如果他们表现得好，就能拿到一大笔钱，一笔奖学金。
I wish to complain about this parrot that I bought not half an hour ago from this very shop.
我想投诉这只鹦鹉，我是半小时前从这家店买的。
Oh, yes. Oh, yes. What is wrong with it?
哦，是的。哦，是的。它怎么了？
I will tell you what is wrong with it.
我来告诉你它怎么了。
He is dead.
它死了。
No. No. No.
不。不。不。
If you're wondering what good this does anybody, the idea, besides amusing yourself and your friends on the discussion boards and administering some karmic justice, is to waste the con men's time so they have fewer hours in the day to scam people. And the bait that I'm going to tell you about today wasted an astonishing amount of the con man's time, maybe more than any bait ever.
如果你想知道这对任何人有什么好处，除了娱乐自己和讨论版上的朋友并实施一些因果报应之外，这个主意是为了浪费骗子的时间，这样他们一天里用来诈骗别人的时间就少了。而今天我要告诉你们的这个诱饵浪费了骗子惊人的时间，可能比以往任何诱饵浪费的时间都多。
It began when somebody on the discussion board got ahold of a scam email from a Nigerian whose name was supposedly Adamu. He wrote to this Adamu, pretending to be an official from a missionary church, which is a time-tested bait.
事情始于讨论版上有人收到了一封据称来自尼日利亚人亚当（Adamu）的诈骗邮件。他写信给这个亚当，冒充传教士教会的官员，这是一个久经考验的诱饵。
Well, the way it typically worked was one of these scammers would contact the church. We would write back and say, well, unless you're a member of the church, we really can't get involved in any financial transactions with you, so if you want to become a member, great, otherwise good luck with your transaction. Then they decide that they want the money really bad. They join the church and we just plan from there.
嗯，通常的运作方式是其中一个骗子会联系教会。我们会写信回复说，嗯，除非你是教会成员，否则我们真的不能参与任何与你的财务交易，所以如果你想成为会员，太好了，否则祝你的交易好运。然后他们决定他们非常想要这笔钱。他们加入了教会，我们从那里开始计划。
The idea, YeaWhatever says, is to get the scammer off of his script for what's going to happen and onto theirs, which worked with this guy Adamu.
“管他呢”说，这个主意是为了让骗子脱离他们预定的诈骗剧本，进入他们的剧本，这在亚当这个家伙身上奏效了。
Well, we got him totally in a different direction. We offered him grant money to start a church in Nigeria.
嗯，我们完全把他引向了另一个方向。我们主动提出给他资助金，让他去尼日利亚建立一个教会。
And how much did you offer him?
你们给了他多少钱？
$200,000.
20万美元。
But if Adamu wanted to get the $200,000, they told him, he would have to take a trip, a long trip, from Lagos, Nigeria to a completely different country, Chad. When baiters send a con man on this kind of trip, they refer to it as a safari. It's a wild goose chase, basically, but, of course, that's not what they told Adamu.
但他们告诉亚当，如果他想拿到这20万美元，他就必须去一趟，从尼日利亚拉各斯出发，去一个完全不同的国家——乍得。当诱饵者让骗子进行这种旅行时，他们称之为“游猎”。这基本上就是一场徒劳的奔波，当然，他们没告诉亚当。
They invented an entire cast of made-up characters who started emailing and occasionally telephoning Adamu. All of them were part of this church that they had invented. There was a Reverend Benjamin who informed Adamu that, if Adamu could somehow make it to Chad, there was a missionary named Hamden there and a translator named Eric who would meet him and drive him to where he would get the $200,000. Here's Jojo.
他们虚构了整套角色，开始给亚当发邮件，偶尔还打电话。他们都是他们虚构出的那个教会的一部分。有一位本杰明牧师告诉亚当，如果他能设法到达乍得，那里有一位名叫哈姆丹（Hamden）的传教士和一位名叫埃里克（Eric）的翻译会见到他，并开车送他去拿那20万美元。这是乔乔。
We basically said, what you need to do is you need to get a one-way ticket from Nigeria to N'Djamena, Chad, which is right on the border of Nigeria. It's about 800 or 900 miles away. You don't need to worry about clothes or food, because once you get there, everything's going to be provided for you.
我们基本上说，你需要做的是买一张从尼日利亚到乍得恩贾梅纳的单程票，那里就在尼日利亚边境。大约有800或900英里远。你不需要担心衣服或食物，因为一旦你到了那里，一切都会为你准备好。
And we're going to send our missionary, Hamden. We're going to send him to pick you up in N'Djamena, and you're going to leave with the $200,000. You know, everything's going to be taken care of once you get to N'Djamena.
我们要派我们的传教士哈姆丹去恩贾梅纳接你，你会带着20万美元离开。你知道，一旦你到了恩贾梅纳，一切都会安排妥当的。
To help the church representatives recognize Adamu in the town square in N'Djamena, they ask Adamu to wear a white robe and a bright pink sash, and hold a sign with a slightly obscene message about Muhammad, this in the middle of a Muslim country.
为了帮助教会代表在恩贾梅纳的城镇广场认出亚当，他们要求亚当穿上一件白袍，系上一条鲜亮的粉红色腰带，并举着一张写有关于穆罕默德稍微有点猥亵信息标语的牌子，这可是在一个穆斯林国家的中心。
Now, to give you a sense of what Chad is like, somebody posted on the scam baiter discussion board the official travel advisory for Chad that was issued by the Canadian government. It describes the entire country as unstable. Possible clashes between rebels and government troops, it says. Civil unrest and violent incidents can occur at all times, including in N'Djamena, Adamu's first stop. There are live mine fields. There are roaming armed militias. There are bandits.
现在，为了让你了解乍得是什么样子，有人在诈骗诱饵讨论版上发布了加拿大政府发布的乍得官方旅行建议。它将整个国家描述为不稳定。称可能发生叛军和政府军之间的冲突。暴力事件和内乱随时可能发生，包括在亚当的第一站恩贾梅纳。那里有地雷区。有游荡的武装民兵。有强盗。
Yeah, it's very dangerous.
是的，非常危险。
And then are you trying to get him hurt or are you just trying to scare him?
那你是在试图让他受伤，还是仅仅想吓唬他？
No, we're not trying to get him hurt.
不，我们不是要让他受伤。
We're not trying to get him hurt, but it's really just isolating him. What we wanted to do is just isolate him, get him out there, cut off from any ability to communicate with potential real-life victims, and keep him there as long as we could.
我们不是要让他受伤，但这实际上只是在孤立他。我们想做的只是孤立他，把他弄到那里，断绝他与任何潜在的真实受害者沟通的能力，并尽可能长时间地把他留在那里。
And on April 1st, they start getting emails from Adamu saying that he has arrived in Chad, but there is nobody there to meet him. They email back, explaining that Hamden's car broke down on the road halfway between N'Djamena and a town called Abeche, and that's why Hamden isn't there to pick him up.
4月1日，他们开始收到亚当的邮件，说他已经抵达乍得，但没有人来接他。他们回复邮件解释说，哈姆丹的车在恩贾梅纳和阿贝歇（Abeche）镇中间的路上抛锚了，所以哈姆丹才没能去接他。
And right away, Adamu writes back to them saying his situation is pretty rough. He's traveling, by the way, with a man who he identifies as his brother, who may or may not be his real brother.
亚当立刻回复邮件说他的处境非常糟糕。顺便说一下，他和一个他称之为兄弟的男人一起旅行，这可能不是他的亲兄弟。
This is an excerpt from something on April 3rd. "Please, I am not OK here. Since four days now, I am stranded in N'Djamena. The worst is I don't have single money with me here. Please--" [LAUGHS] You know, it's hard to read these without even laughing. "Please, for God's sake, tell Hamden to come today or latest tomorrow. No food for me. No water to drink, because of the language problem. No English, only Arabic language and Hausa. That is why I come with my brother that can speak Hausa but not Arabic. I am very, very hungry."
这是4月3日某封邮件的节选。“求求你，我在这里很不好。这四天来，我一直滞留在恩贾梅纳。最糟糕的是我身上连一分钱都没有。求求你……”[笑] 你知道，读这些话时很难不笑。“求求你，看在上帝的份上，叫哈姆丹今天或最晚明天来。我没东西吃，没水喝，因为语言不通。我不懂英语，只会阿拉伯语和豪萨语。这就是为什么我带了能说豪萨语但我不会阿拉伯语的兄弟。我非常非常饿。”
And he writes in another email around the same time, "You call me as soon as you reach. Please. No food, no water since four days now." What do you think's really happening? Do you really believe that he has no food and no water?
他在同一时间左右写的另一封邮件里说：“你一到就打给我。求你了。这四天来没东西吃，没水喝。”你觉得真的发生了什么？你真的相信他没东西吃没水喝吗？
No.
不。
Nope. I mean, he's got money to check the internet. You know, what kind of priorities are those? These guys are used to telling lies for a living. I don't disagree that it probably is pretty bad there, but he's not as hungry as he claims.
没。我是说，他有钱上网检查邮箱。你知道，那是些什么优先事项啊？这些家伙习惯于以撒谎为生。我不否认那里可能情况确实很糟糕，但他并没有他声称的那么饿。
For the next few weeks, the truth of Adamu's situation, as best as they can figure, is this. He's living at the bus station, sleeping outside, still in the same clothes he arrived in. He has a little money to email them from the internet cafe, but very soon his cellphone dies.
在接下来的几周里，据他们所知，亚当处境的真相是这样的：他住在公交车站，睡在外面，仍然穿着他刚到时穿的那身衣服。他有一些钱在网吧给他们发邮件，但很快他的手机就没电了。
This is pretty much exactly the kind of misery that the baiters had hoped to inflict in the first place. And on the discussion boards with their peers, there's a lot of high-fiving and celebration. "Ha ha ha. I love this," somebody writes. "I almost feel sorry for him, but not really."
这几乎正是诱饵者最初希望造成的苦难。在讨论版上，他们的同伴们大肆击掌庆祝。“哈哈哈哈。我喜欢这个，”有人写道。“我几乎有点同情他了，但也不是真的。”
And at this point, the baiters move to phase two of their plan. N'Djamena is bad, but now they do everything they can to convince Adamu to come to Abeche, 400 miles further from home, and 400 miles closer to a part of the world you've probably heard of, Darfur, which is just on the other side of the border between Chad and Sudan. Phase two will take him to the town of Abeche, which is still in Chad but less than 100 miles from the border. Conditions there are much more dangerous than in N'Djamena.
此时，诱饵者进入了计划的第二阶段。恩贾梅纳很糟，但现在他们尽一切可能说服亚当前往阿贝歇，距离家乡更远了400英里，也向你可能听说过的那个世界——达尔富尔，更近了400英里，达尔富尔就在乍得和苏丹的边境另一侧。第二阶段将把他带到阿贝歇镇，该镇仍在乍得境内，但距离边境不到100英里。那里的条件比恩贾梅纳危险得多。
If he hits Abeche, Professor So And So writes on the discussion board, he is more screwed than he can even imagine. To lure him there, they send him fake receipts for Western Union money transfers that he can only pick up at the Western Union office in Abeche. They try to convince him to join Hamden, whose car is supposedly still stuck halfway to Abeche.
“如果他到了阿贝歇，”某某教授在讨论版上写道，“他比他能想象的还要惨。”为了诱骗他去那里，他们寄给他伪造的西联汇款收据，他只能在阿贝歇的西联汇款办公室领取。他们试图说服他去和哈姆丹汇合，哈姆丹的车据称还在去阿贝歇的路上抛锚着。
And YeaWhatever writes an email, pretending to be Eric, the church's translator, talking about how great it is all going to be once he gets to Abeche. If YeaWhatever and his buddies sound surprisingly gleeful as they talk about this, well, we'll get to that.
“管他呢”写了一封邮件，冒充教会的翻译埃里克，谈论一旦他到了阿贝歇一切都会变得多么美好。如果“管他呢”和他的哥们儿在谈论这些时听起来出奇地幸灾乐祸，嗯，我们稍后再说。
"Brother Adamu, you'll be happy to know that Abeche is a quiet, very small town, just a couple hundred people. Unlike N'Djamena, everything in Abeche is easy to find and everyone there is far more friendly." Really not true, but--
“亚当兄弟，你会很高兴知道阿贝歇是一个安静的小镇，只有几百人。与恩贾梅纳不同，在阿贝歇一切都很容易找到，每个人都友好得多。”这真不是真的，但是……
"We live in a building exactly 20 meters to the west of the UN office. It's easy to find that building. It is the only building in the center of town that has satellite dishes all over it." We don't really know if there is such a building, but we thought it sounded nice.
“我们住在一栋离联合国办公室以西20米的建筑里。很容易找到那栋楼。它是市中心唯一一栋上面满是卫星天线的建筑。”我们不知道是否真的有这样一栋建筑，但我们觉得听起来不错。
"Anyhow, everyone knows us in Abeche. All you need to do is ask for Hamden or me. Everyone knows us. I look forward to finally meeting you and your brother. This has taken way too long already. I'm sure that both you and your brother are looking forward to the plane ride back home."
“总之，在阿贝歇每个人都认识我们。你只需要找哈姆丹或我。每个人都认识我们。我期待着终于见到你和你的兄弟。这已经花费了太长时间了。我相信你和你的兄弟都期待着乘飞机回家。”
So you're trying to get him to Abeche, and at one point you actually email him saying, OK, the guy's coming today with the car. And then he doesn't answer that email fast enough, and then you email him again saying, where were you? We sent the guy with the car.
所以你们在试图让他去阿贝歇，有一次你们甚至发邮件说，好的，那人今天开车过来了。然后他没及时回复那封邮件，你们又发邮件说，你上哪儿去了？我们派人开车过去了。
We actually had the driver call him. I asked--
我们确实让司机打电话给他。我问……
You had him call him?
你们让他打电话？
Yeah, another baiter. I asked him if he would make the call. So he had voice modulation software and software that he could add sounds, so he put a sound of, like, a busy street on and called as the driver freaking out on him about not being able to find him and waiting two hours.
是的，另一个诱饵者。我问他是否愿意打这个电话。他有语音调制软件和可以添加音效的软件，所以他加了一些像繁忙街道的声音，假装成那个因为找不到他而气急败坏、等了两个小时的司机。
Wait a minute. I've been trying to call this number for two hours. I went there to pick you up, ain't nobody there. And damn it, I'm crotchety. You know what? He gave me some money to give to you. I'm on my way back now. I'm leaving.
等一下。我两小时来一直在打这个号码。我过去接你，一个人都没有。该死的，我很暴躁。你知道吗？他给我钱让我给你。我正在回去的路上。我要走了。
He told him he was keeping the money, and then we had to follow up and let him know exactly what happened. He missed the driver.
他告诉他他要把钱留着，然后我们得跟进，让他确切知道发生了什么。他错过了司机。
So that's just to make him feel as bad as possible, it seems.
所以这只是为了让他感觉尽可能糟糕，看来是这样。
It was his fault.
是他的错。
Oh, right.
哦，对。
It's to make it his fault, you know, essentially.
本质上是为了让他觉得是他的错。
That's one thing we like to do, is it's never anyone's-- well, it's never any of our fault. It's always their fault. It's not our fault. It's Western Union's fault. It's not our fault that you didn't get the email. The driver was there. You know, so we create this illusion that we are being so very compliant with everything they're asking for.
我们喜欢做的一件事就是，这从来不是任何人的……好吧，这从来不是我们的错。总是他们的错。不是我们的错。是西联汇款的错。你没收到邮件不是我们的错。司机去了。你知道，所以我们制造了一种错觉，即我们非常配合他们要求的一切。
This technique is exactly what the scammers do themselves. They tell you that they are doing everything possible to help you get your money. But there's always one more problem that prevents you from getting the big payout, one more hoop to go through. The scam baiters are like cops, taking the same tactics as the criminals.
这种技术正是骗子自己使用的手段。他们告诉你，他们正在尽一切可能帮助你拿到钱。但总有一个问题阻碍你拿到那笔大钱，总有一个圈套要钻。诈骗诱饵者就像警察，采用和罪犯一样的战术。
Don't they recognize the fact that you're using the same technique on them that they use on the people who they're scamming?
他们难道没有意识到你们在用他们对待受害者的相同技术来对付他们吗？
It baffles us. You would think they would, but they don't. You would think so.
这让我们很困惑。你会以为他们会的，但他们没有。你本以为会的。
Well, the obvious difference with us is we're not asking for money. We're just asking him to travel from one place to another, so maybe that's enough for them not to see it. It seems to work time and time again.
嗯，我们之间明显的区别在于我们没要钱。我们只是要求他从一个地方旅行到另一个地方，所以也许这足以让他们看不出来。这似乎一次又一次地奏效了。
And then once you get him isolated, once you get him, you know, somewhere like N'Djamena, well, they really don't have an option but to believe. You know, it's the same mentality that some of these victims have. They've sent so much, they've gone this far, that they can't really turn back at this point.
一旦你把他孤立，一旦你把他弄到像恩贾梅纳那样的地方，好吧，他们确实没有选择，只能相信。你知道，这和那些受害者拥有的心态是一样的。他们已经寄了这么多，走到这一步了，所以他们在这个时候真的无法回头了。
In a thread on your discussion board, people talk about this victim mentality. Once you've given up some money or some time to actually believe that it's a scam, it's just too horrible to think about, and it's just easier to think, oh, this is going to work out.
在你们讨论版的一个帖子中，人们谈论这种受害者心态。一旦你放弃了一些钱或时间去真正相信这是一个骗局，想一想就太可怕了，而认为“哦，这会成功的”反而更容易。
Right. And I think the same thing holds true with them.
没错。我认为同样的逻辑也适用于他们。
The guys managed to keep Adamu and his brother waiting in N'Djamena for 21 days, which is an incredibly long time for one of these scam bait safaris. Usually they just last a day or two. And they are nowhere near finished.
这几个人设法让亚当和他的兄弟在恩贾梅纳等了21天，对于这些诈骗诱饵游猎来说，这时间长得令人难以置信。通常它们只持续一两天。而且他们远没有结束。
They do manage to convince Adamu to go to Abeche, where conditions, as predicted, are much, much worse. Adamu gets there by telling a driver that he will pay the driver $500 when they arrive in Abeche. All they have to do is go to the Western Union office in Abeche, where, supposedly, money is waiting for them, sent by the church.
他们确实设法说服亚当去阿贝歇，那里的条件正如预期的那样，非常非常糟糕。亚当是通过告诉司机他们一到阿贝歇就付给司机500美元才到达那里的。他们所要做的就是去阿贝歇的西联汇款办公室，据称教会寄给他们的钱在那里等着他们。
Though, of course, when they show up, something is wrong with the paperwork at Western Union. They have no money to give the driver, who gets angry. Adamu writes increasingly desperate emails to his friends in the fake church. Each one begins with a pleading reminder that they are at the cyber cafe on Hospital Road, waiting for the church officials to finally arrive and rescue them.
当然，当他们出现时，西联汇款的文书工作出了问题。他们没钱付给司机，司机很生气。亚当给假教会的朋友写了越来越绝望的邮件。每一封邮件开头都带着恳求的提醒，说他们正待在医院路上的网吧里，等着教会官员最终赶到并救他们。
"My life is in great danger here because of the driver that has brought us here have not been pay and he is treating our life."
“我的生命在这里有巨大的危险，因为带我们来这里的司机还没拿到报酬，他正在威胁我们的生命。”
Threatening, I guess.
我想应该是威胁。
These are being read as written, so--
这些都是按原话读的，所以……
Yeah.
是的。
"Now there is tension--" [LAUGHS] "there is tension all over my body because of the driver threating me of his money. Save me from the driver hand, because he is increase his money every day. I and my brother have been with him now for five days in Abeche."
“现在我的全身都有压力……”[笑] “因为司机威胁要钱，我的全身都有压力。从司机手中救救我，因为他每天都在增加要钱的金额。我和我的兄弟在阿贝歇和他在一起已经五天了。”
And do you think it's possible at this point that the driver is threatening them? That seems like it could be possible, right?
你认为在这一点上司机威胁他们是真的吗？这看起来可能是真的，对吧？
Yes, completely.
是的，完全可能。
Definitely.
肯定的。
Oh, yeah. I mean, I don't doubt that one bit. I mean, it's his phone they're using. He's paying for cafe time.
哦，是的。我是说，我一点也不怀疑。我是说，他们用的是他的手机。他在支付上网费。
Now, you write underneath this on the bulletin board posting, Jojo, "These are some of the funniest emails I've ever seen." And I want to ask you about this, because on the discussion board, as you're posting this day-by-day as it's happening, people all through it are saying, "This is knee-slappingly funny stuff. I am laughing so hard at these emails."
现在，你在布告栏上写道，乔乔，“这是我见过的最有趣的邮件。”我想问你这个，因为在讨论版上，当你在事情发生时逐日发布这些内容时，人们一直都在说，“这真是让人笑破肚皮的东西。我看着这些邮件笑得太厉害了。”
You post on the bulletin board, saying, "If the following email doesn't make you laugh out loud, then we would never have fun hanging out. This is pure poetry to me." And the email is, "I am begging you in the name of our Lord Jesus Christ, I and my brother are still waiting for you in Abeche in the only cyber cafe along Hospital Road. We are waiting for you. We are still here since the driver is not happy about us. Please come so that we will be free from his hand. Please. Thank you. I am waiting."
你在布告栏上贴了一段话，说：“如果接下来的这封邮件没让你大笑出声，那我们永远也不会玩在一起。这对我来说简直是纯粹的诗歌。”那封邮件是，“我以我们主耶稣基督的名义恳求你们，我和我的兄弟还在阿贝歇医院路唯一的网吧等着你们。我们正在等你们。我们还在这里，因为司机对我们很不满。请过来，这样我们就不用受他摆布了。求你了。谢谢。我正在等。”
That's just gold.
那简直是黄金。
Can I ask you? I think that this is just an area where I am not going to see eye to eye on this. I don't see what's funny about this.
我能问你吗？我觉得这只是一个我无法达成共识的领域。我不觉得这有什么好笑的。
Yeah, you've got to realize, again, these guys are overly dramatic. I understand that it is, you know, it's not the safest place in the world, but this is just a bit of drama here.
是的，你必须意识到，这些家伙非常戏剧化。我明白这不是世界上最安全的地方，但这就只是点戏剧成分。
Well, again, these are not nice people, you know? And if you've been dealing with people like this as long as we have, you might find some humor in this. But I guess to people who don't do what we do, this might be a bit shocking and maybe not so funny. But again, we deal with people like this all the time, and they will tell you any lie possible to get money out of you. And they want their money and they'll do whatever it takes to get it.
嗯，再次说明，这些人不是好人，你知道吗？如果你处理像这样的人和我们一样久，你可能会从中找到一些幽默感。但我猜对于不干我们这行的人来说，这可能有点令人震惊，也许不太好笑。但再说一次，我们一直在和这样的人打交道，他们会说出任何可能的谎言来骗你的钱。他们想要他们的钱，他们会不惜一切代价得到它。
In all, Adamu and his brother wait for the church officials to show up at the cyber cafe on Hospital Road for nearly three months, all of May, and all of June, and most of July. Meanwhile, the baiters switch tactics against them over and over. They keep sending Adamu into the Western Union office to pick up money transfers that never go through. Once, they send him in with a note written in Arabic, a language Adamu does not speak, to show the clerk. Here's what the note says.
总而言之，亚当和他的兄弟在医院路的网吧里等教会官员出现近三个月，整个五月、整个六月，以及七月的大部分时间。与此同时，诱饵者一次又一次地改变对他们的战术。他们不断地让亚当去西联汇款办公室领取从未到账的汇款。有一次，他们让他带着一张用阿拉伯语写的字条去，亚当不会说阿拉伯语，让他展示给职员看。字条上是这么写的。
I am a criminal. Please arrest me. I hate Muhammad and Mecca is a hell hole. I love Israel. I love George Bush. I think he should invade Chad and remove this ugly country off the map. Muhammad is a demonic pedophile. I hate Muslims. I hate Chad. I hate this country and its people. I'm about to rob this place.
我是个罪犯。请逮捕我。我讨厌穆罕默德，麦加是个地狱。我爱以色列。我爱乔治·布什。我认为他应该入侵乍得，把这个丑陋的国家从地图上抹去。穆罕默德是个邪恶的恋童癖。我讨厌穆斯林。我讨厌乍得。我讨厌这个国家及其人民。我快要抢劫这个地方了。
Do you know if he actually showed this to the Western Union person?
你知道他真的把这个给西联汇款的人看了吗？
He did not show it to the Western Union person.
他没有给西联汇款的人看。
Nothing happened.
什么也没发生。
We were hoping at that point to get him arrested.
我们当时希望让他被捕。
I don't think he really brought it there. No way.
我不觉得他真的带去了。不可能。
At some point during this time in Abeche, Adamu starts saying that his brother is injured. His brother's leg was hurt, Adamu says, when they fled a rebel battle. To find out what was true and what was just another lie, I tried to contact Adamu by email and by telephone. I got some help from a Nigerian journalist in Lagos. He talked to Adamu several times, tried to convince him to come on the air, and give his side of this whole story. Adamu refused. He said he knew nothing about this, that we must have the wrong man.
在阿贝歇的这段时间里，亚当开始说他的兄弟受伤了。亚当说，在他们逃离一场叛军战斗时，他兄弟的腿受伤了。为了弄清楚什么是真，什么是又一个谎言，我尝试通过电子邮件和电话联系亚当。我从拉各斯的一位尼日利亚记者那里得到了一些帮助。他多次与亚当交谈，试图说服他上节目，说出这个故事的他的版本。亚当拒绝了。他说他对此一无所知，我们肯定是认错人了。
But back when Adamu was still in Abeche, the baiters came up with a way to intercept the emails that Adamu sent to two guys who appear to be his bosses back home in Nigeria, and also to intercept the emails that those two guys sent to him.
但在亚当还在阿贝歇时，诱饵者想出了一种方法来拦截亚当发送给尼日利亚老家那两个据说是他老板的家伙的邮件，也拦截了那两个人发给他的邮件。
This is one of the emails that Adamu sends to those guys back home about all this. Remember, he has no idea that the baiters are reading his private emails, so this is about as close as we ever get to seeing how bad his situation really was. Professor So And So reads.
这是亚当发给那两个老家的人关于这一切的邮件之一。记住，他根本不知道诱饵者在读他的私人邮件，所以这大约是我们能看到他处境到底有多糟糕的极限了。“某某教授”来读。
Dear CZ, we are in great danger now. Please, can you call [? Annie ?] to go and borrow money for us, because brother is in danger if he die here? All of us are in a big problem.
亲爱的CZ，我们现在处于极大的危险中。求求你，能不能叫[？安妮？]去为我们借点钱，因为如果兄弟死在这里，我就没命了？我们所有人都陷入了巨大的麻烦中。
And jump down to the next one where he's writing ND.
跳到下一封，他写给ND的那封。
Sure. Dear ND, ND, we are not happy with your email you send to us. I told you that we are in danger here in Chad and brother broke his leg because of the attack, the rebel attack us here. We escaped by god help and there's no one to assist us. We are sleeping outside since in the desert. Please, ND, don't let us die here because of transport money to come back home. Please.
好的。亲爱的ND，ND，我们对你发给我们的邮件很不高兴。我告诉你我们在乍得处于危险之中，因为袭击，叛军袭击了我们，兄弟摔断了腿。我们在上帝的帮助下逃脱了，没有人来协助我们。我们自从在沙漠里就一直睡在外面。求求你，ND，不要因为回家的交通费就让我们死在这里。求你了。
And so, do you think the brother's leg is hurt?
所以，你觉得他兄弟的腿真的受伤了吗？
I don't know.
我不知道。
I don't know. I do think there might be something to that, because that is kind of a recurring theme.
我不知道。我确实认为这可能有些什么，因为那是一个反复出现的主题。
Well, in the last call that I had with Adamu, he was explaining about how his brother got really sick and, you know, they were having a hard time begging for medication money. And there was something in his voice when I was talking with him that I actually did believe that something happened.
嗯，在我与亚当的最后一次通话中，他解释了他兄弟怎么变得病得很重，而且，你知道，他们很难乞讨到医药费。当我与他交谈时，他的声音里有些东西，我确实相信发生了什么事。
Yeah. He's there a total of 106 days, he's gone from home. And then when we were talking with him on the phone one day, I think he's just kind of given up hope. You know, he doesn't have money to check his email. I think he's just kind of frustrated at the way things have gone. And we end up telling him that his mother died, which was a pretty big deal. He hasn't really been in contact with home, as far as we know.
是的。他一共在那里待了106天，他离家很久了。然后有一天我们在电话里和他谈话时，我觉得他已经放弃希望了。你知道，他没钱检查邮件。我觉得他只是对事情的发展感到沮丧。最后我们告诉他，他母亲去世了，这可是件大事。据我们所知，他与家里并没有真正联系。
At that point, we were just kind of getting bored with him. I mean, there wasn't much else we could do with him. We knew he wasn't going to travel anywhere else. I don't know. We had nothing to lose and thought, why not?
在那个时候，我们只是有点厌倦他了。我是说，我们对他也没什么其他办法了。我们知道他哪儿也不会去。我不知道。我们没什么好失去的，心想，为什么不呢？
Don't you think that's kind of harsh, telling somebody that their mother's dead?
你不觉得告诉某人他们的母亲去世了有点太苛刻了吗？
Yeah, that's a little creepy. I don't know. We were talking one morning and I don't remember who came up with the idea, but it didn't sit right for a minute or two, and I thought, well, why not? So we went with it.
是的，那有点阴森。我不知道。我们一天早上在谈话，我不记得是谁想出的主意，但那一刻感觉不太对，我想，好吧，为什么不呢？所以我们还是照做了。
But think about the irony of this. That's one thing that's kind of funny, was the response on the forum. You know, the same people that were like, oh, this is great, this is hilarious, you sent him to Chad, oh, I can't believe you've fictitiously killed his mom.
但想想这件事的讽刺之处。有一件事确实有点滑稽，那就是论坛上的反应。你知道，同样的人，之前还在说，“哦，这太棒了，这太搞笑了，你们把他送到了乍得”，现在却说，“哦，我不敢相信你们编造了他妈死了的事实。”
Right. That's going too far.
没错。那太过分了。
Sending him to Chad and the border of Darfur is fine--
把他送到乍得和达尔富尔边境是没问题的……
Which is real.
那是真实的。
--but fictitiously killing his mom, oh, that's, you know, that's harsh.
……但是编造他妈死了，哦，那是，你知道，那是苛刻。
Kind of struck me odd, too.
我也觉得有点奇怪。
Right, but it's like you're playing with his heart when you're talking about his mom.
没错，但这就像你在谈论他妈时是在玩弄他的心。
Right.
没错。
Somehow that seems like it's out of the game. Like, you're sending him on a goose chase to get $200,000 that he's trying to steal from a church. OK, you know, you're sort of playing his game with him. But to tell him about his mom, that's just like-- it's so personal.
无论如何，这看起来似乎已经超出了游戏范围。就像，你把他送去徒劳地追求他试图从教会偷来的20万美元。好吧，你知道，你算是和他一起玩他的游戏。但告诉他关于他妈的事，那真的就像是……这太私人了。
I know. And I know it does sound kind of creepy at first. But again, we've been dealing with people like this for years and, I don't know, maybe we've just become jaded over time. But I don't know, it doesn't really bother me when we pull something like this on a guy, because his mom's not really dead.
我知道。我知道这起初听起来确实有点阴森。但再次说明，我们和这样的人打交道多年了，我不知道，也许我们随着时间推移已经变得麻木了。但我不知道，当我们对一个人做这种事时，我真的不觉得困扰，因为他妈并没有真的死。
Every now and then in the 106 days in the discussion boards, their peers would tentatively raise questions about the ethics of what they were doing, of intentionally sending somebody like Adamu, a petty thief who all these guys see as inexperienced and naive, to the most violent place they could with no money or even a change of clothes.
在106天里的讨论版上，他们的同伴偶尔会试探性地提出关于他们所做之事道德伦理的问题，关于故意把像亚当这样的人——一个被所有这些人视为没经验且幼稚的小偷——送到他们能找到的最暴力的地方，身上没钱甚至没换洗衣服。
One poster writes, "At this point I wonder to myself, what would make me feel sorry for a lad," meaning for one of these guys. And somebody responds, "Call me a no fun lad hugger, but I reached that point early on. Yes, he is a scammer and scumwad. On the other hand, he is also, technically speaking, a human being, and I've been wincing whenever anybody gleefully expresses the possibility that he might die. Don't get me wrong. I'm laughing my head off. But I'm also feeling a little bit uneasy as I'm laughing." Somebody else writes, "He could seriously get killed. Am I bad for thinking that's pretty cool?"
有一个发帖者写道：“到了这一步，我自问，什么能让我同情一个家伙，”指的是这些人中的一个。有人回应说：“叫我个无趣的家伙拥护者吧，但我很早就到了那一步。是的，他是个骗子和渣滓。但另一方面，严格来说，他也是个人，每当有人幸灾乐祸地表示他可能会死时，我都会退缩。别误会。我笑得前仰后合。但我笑的时候也感到有点不安。”还有人写道：“他可能会真的被杀。觉得那很酷，我是坏人吗？”
Right, I remember reading that.
没错，我记得读过那个。
What's your reaction to that?
你对此有什么反应？
Well, I think people come up with these hypothetical scenarios in their brain. I mean, honestly, Ira, you're in New York City, I assume, and you could get killed there. I mean, people get killed everywhere every day.
嗯，我认为人们会在大脑里想出这些假设的场景。我是说，老实说，艾拉，你在纽约市，我假设是这样，你也可能在那里被杀。我是说，每天到处都有人被杀。
I know, but you're specifically sending him to a place where there's violence and where there's warnings not to go there and you're putting him in a dangerous situation. Like, well, what if he did get killed? I mean, do you fear that? If that happened, would you feel like, oh, we went too far?
我知道，但你是在特意把他送到一个有暴力的地方，那里有警告不要去，你把他置于危险的境地。就像，嗯，如果他真的被杀了呢？我是说，你担心那个吗？如果发生了那种事，你会觉得，哦，我们做得太过了吗？
Well, I understand this is not going to make me the most popular guy in the world, but it wouldn't really bother me all that much to be honest with you. These guys are pure scum as far as I'm concerned. And they don't have to go there. We just kind of put the bait out there and they went for it. These people think they're stealing from a church and stealing from humanitarian workers, so if they got killed, well, it's two less scammers in the world.
嗯，我知道这不会让我成为世界上最受欢迎的人，但老实说，这真的不会让我太困扰。在我看来，这些家伙纯粹是渣滓。他们没必要去那里。我们只是把诱饵放出来，他们就上钩了。这些人以为他们是在从教会偷钱，从人道主义工作者那里偷钱，所以如果他们被杀了，嗯，世界上就少了两个骗子。
And, Jojo, what do you think?
那么，乔乔，你觉得呢？
You know, I don't know that I would sleep greatly at night if I knew that, but I wouldn't feel responsible. I would feel like their greed led them there, that they chose to get up and go to Abeche.
你知道，我不知道如果我知道那样的话，我晚上还能不能睡好，但我不会觉得自己有责任。我会觉得是他们的贪婪把他们带到了那里，是他们选择了起身去阿贝歇。
But it wouldn't have-- if one of them were to get really, really hurt or killed, like, it wouldn't have happened except for you.
但这不会……如果他们中有人真的真的受重伤或被杀，比如，如果不是因为你们，就不会发生了。
It wouldn't have happened if it hadn't been for them. You seem to be taking that out of the equation. It's their scamming, it's their falling for this and trying to rip us off that got them into it.
如果不是因为他们，就不会发生了。你似乎把那部分从等式里去掉了。是他们的诈骗，是他们的上钩并试图敲诈我们才让他们陷入了这些。
Of course, Adamu could say exactly the same thing about his victims, about the Americans who fall for his email scams, that it's their own greed, trying to snag millions from a Nigerian bank, that gets them into it. If at this point you're wondering why this is the cause that these three guys took as their own, why they feel so strongly about this particular issue versus all the possible injustices they could be fighting, they all say they just kind of fell into it. None of these guys has personally lost money in an email scam, though they all know about people who've lost lots of money. YeaWhatever says he talked to a guy in Florida who just lost his house, was in tears, asking for help, but nothing could be done for him.
当然，亚当对于他的受害者，对于那些掉进他电子邮件骗局的美国人，也可以说完全一样的话，是他们自己的贪婪，试图从尼日利亚银行窃取数百万美元，才让他们陷入了这些。如果到了这一点，你想知道为什么这三个人会把这项事业当作自己的，为什么他们对这个问题如此坚定，而不是去对抗所有他们能对抗的可能的非正义，他们都说他们只是碰巧卷进来了。这些人中没有一个人在电子邮件骗局中个人损失过金钱，尽管他们都知道有人损失了很多钱。 “管他呢”说他和一个在佛罗里达刚失去房子、泪流满面寻求帮助的家伙谈过，但对他无能为力。
Knowing that this radio story about them was going to be on the air in the last couple of days, they started talking, naturally, about the radio story on their discussion board. YeaWhatever wrote, "I'm sure that we'll be painted to look like ass [BLEEP], but I am totally OK with that. We are ass [BLEEP]." Professor So And So agreed. "Big time ass [BLEEP]."
知道这个关于他们的电台报道在过去几天会播出，他们自然开始在讨论版上谈论这篇报道。“管他呢”写道：“我相信我们会被描绘成混蛋[哔——]，但我完全接受。我们就是混蛋[哔——]。”“某某教授”表示赞同。“大大的混蛋[哔——]。”
Professor So And So, by the way, is the only one of these three baiters who has ever had any second thoughts about anything they did in this bait, maybe because he's the least experienced. He's been baiting for less than a year. At first, Professor So And So says, he wasn't so sure that they should tell Adamu that his mom was dead.
顺便说一下，“某某教授”是这三个诱饵者中唯一一个对他们在这个诱饵中所做的任何事情有过反思的人，也许是因为他最缺乏经验。他参与诱饵的时间不到一年。起初，“某某教授”说，他不确定他们是否应该告诉亚当他妈死了。
Well, it was interesting to really just kind of analyze as I was feeling. It's like, why does that feel like that? I mean, I knew it was something that I wanted to do, and I knew it was because it was really just-- I don't know. It was something that--
嗯，分析我当时的感受真的很有趣。就像，为什么会有那种感觉？我是说，我知道那是我想要做的事情，我知道这是因为它真的是……我不知道。那是某件……
Sadistic?
施虐倾向？
Yeah, I guess so. I mean, it was a piece of psychological torture, that-- I think the feeling that he would have, you know, at that moment being so far and so isolated and so out of touch and, you know, at this point it was purely psychological, what we were doing.
是的，我想是吧。我是说，这是一种心理折磨，那……我认为他在那一刻感受到的那种感觉，身处那么远、那么孤立、那么与世隔绝，你知道，在这一点上，我们所做的纯粹是心理上的。
And then what made you then go ahead and do it if you had the hesitation?
如果你有这种犹豫，是什么让你最终还是去做了？
Well, because the hesitation wasn't stronger than, I guess, the desire to leave him with that feeling for even a short period of time.
嗯，因为那种犹豫并没有比我想让他感受到那种感觉的愿望更强烈，即使只是一小段时间。
Not long after they told Adamu that his mother had died, he must have called home and learned the truth. After that, the guys say, he seemed to understand that something fishy was going on.
在他们告诉亚当他母亲去世后不久，他一定打了电话回家并得知了真相。在那之后，他们说，他似乎明白有些事情不对劲。
They lost contact with him. Pretty soon he managed to get home to Nigeria, which is where he is now back in business trying to do his email scams, which we know because Jojo is still in contact with him. Jojo's got a different bait going now. Jojo's posing this time as a single dad named Pancho Villa.
他们和他失去了联系。很快他设法回到了尼日利亚，他现在就在那里又回到了生意场上，试图搞他的电子邮件骗局，我们知道这一点是因为乔乔还在和他联系。乔乔现在有了另一个诱饵。乔乔这次冒充的是一个叫潘乔·比利亚（Pancho Villa）的单身爸爸。
I just got an email from him today. He's asking for his $10,000 fee. And I told him, I said, my daughter is very sick and she's in the hospital. I said, I either have the choice to pay my daughter's hospital bills and pay for her treatment or I can send the money to you.
我今天刚收到他的一封邮件。他要求他的1万美元费用。我告诉他，我说，我女儿病得很重，在医院。我说，我要么有选择支付我女儿的医药费并支付她的治疗费用，要么我可以把钱寄给你。
Here's his response, "Let me advise you on the best possible things you should do. Right now, I will advise you to go to the bank, withdraw the money in there, and take it to pay for the consignment fees first. As soon as you pay this, you will use the rest of the money to pay the hospital bill."
这是他的回复，“让我建议你应该做的最好的事情。现在，我建议你直接去银行，把里面的钱取出来，先拿去支付佣金。一旦你支付了这个，你就会用剩下的钱支付住院费。”
So there he is. He thinks that there's a little girl dying, and his solution is no, no, send me the $10,000, let the girl die, and everything will be OK.
所以他就在那里。他认为有个小女孩快死了，他的解决方案是：不，不，把那1万美元寄给我，让那女孩去死吧，一切都会好起来的。
Jojo says that when Adamu does stuff like this, it's easy not to feel sorry for him for what they did to him in Chad. In the days since Jojo read me that email in the studio, Adamu started to suspect that Pancho Villa was a fake. He got furious and accused Pancho of being the same guy who'd screwed with him back in Chad.
乔乔说，当亚当做这些事情时，他们很容易不会因为他们在乍得对他做的事而感到抱歉。在乔乔在录音棚给我读那封邮件后的几天里，亚当开始怀疑潘乔·比利亚是个假货。他变得暴跳如雷，指责潘乔就是那个在乍得折腾他的人。
He wrote an email saying, "Don't ever in your life email me again because you are a fraudster, old thief. You will die a shameful death. You're a criminal from the poorest country in Africa, Chad." In other words, he thinks Jojo lives in Chad. He thinks he's an African.
他写了一封邮件说：“这辈子都别再给我发邮件了，因为你是个骗子，老贼。你会死得很丢人。你是个来自非洲最贫穷国家乍得的罪犯。”换句话说，他认为乔乔住在乍得。他认为他是个非洲人。
And although he's got that detail wrong, when it comes to Adamu's bigger point, that everything that happened to him in Chad was at the hands of somebody exactly like himself, a fellow email scammer, somebody who tricks people and strings them along, on that point he's exactly right.
虽然他弄错了细节，但说到亚当的核心观点，即他在乍得发生的一切都是出于一个和他一模一样的人之手，一个同行的电子邮件骗子，一个欺骗人并牵着人鼻子走的人，在这一点上，他完全正确。
Coming up, the dirtiest-sounding financial thing you can do on Wall Street, and I am not talking about asset strippers. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，在华尔街你能做的听起来最肮脏的金融事情，我说的不是资产剥离者。稍后回来，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, of course, we choose a theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, Enforcers.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，我们每周在节目中都会选择一个主题，并为您带来各种各样的关于该主题的故事。今天的节目主题是“执法者”。
You know, enforcers come in two broad categories. There are vigilantes and there are cops of one kind or another. And we're about to make a leap from one group to the other. We've arrived at act two of our show. Act Two, Now You SEC Me, Now You Don't.
你知道，执法者大致分为两大类。有一类是治安维持者，另一类是各种警察。我们即将从一个群体跨越到另一个群体。我们已经到达了节目的第二幕。第二幕，《SEC见》。
For a long time now in America, whenever there's been a financial upheaval, a big financial crisis, the three different federal agencies that deal with the financial system have to figure out which of them, who is going to be the enforcer, who is going to step in and fix things.
在美国，很长一段时间以来，每当出现金融动荡、重大金融危机时，处理金融系统的三个不同的联邦机构都必须弄清楚他们中间谁将成为执法者，谁将介入并解决问题。
But in the recent financial turmoil we've been going through in this country, including the news this week about Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac, Alex Blumberg reports that one of the three guys supposedly in charge of policing our economy has been notably absent.
但在我们国家经历的近期金融动荡中，包括本周关于房利美和房地美的消息，亚历克斯·布隆伯格报道说，三位本应负责监管我们经济的人中有一位明显缺席了。
The chairman of the SEC, the Securities and Exchange Commission, is often referred to as Wall Street's top cop. And this past year, a year in which the global financial system seemed perpetually on the verge of collapse, a collapse due in large part to complex, unprecedented, and, as we now know, extremely risky financial products created and sold on Wall Street, you might expect to be hearing a lot from Wall Street's main enforcer.
SEC，即证券交易委员会的主席，通常被称为华尔街的总警长。在过去的一年里，全球金融体系似乎始终处于崩溃的边缘，这种崩溃很大程度上归因于华尔街创造和销售的复杂、前所未有的，正如我们现在所知，极其高风险的金融产品，你可能会期待华尔街的总执法者会发表很多声音。
But Christopher Cox, the current chairman of the SEC, has been noticeably absent from any public house cleaning. Instead, it's been two other government officials who've done the heavy lifting, the Chairman of the Fed, Ben Bernanke, and of course, the Secretary of the Treasury, Henry Paulson, who's been all over television this past week talking about the most recent crisis, the bailout of Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac.
但克里斯托弗·考克斯（Christopher Cox），现任SEC主席，在任何公开的大清扫中都明显缺席。相反，是另外两名政府官员承担了重任，美联储主席本·伯南克，当然还有财政部长亨利·保尔森，他过去一周出现在各家电视台，谈论最近的危机，即对房利美和房地美的救助。
These three men have made regular and frequent appearances before various House and Senate banking and finance committees, the three horsemen of the financial apocalypse. But Christopher Cox can sometimes seem like less a third horseman and more a third wheel.
这三个人定期且频繁地出现在众议院和参议院的各个银行和金融委员会面前，是金融灾难的“三骑士”。但克里斯托弗·考克斯有时看起来不像第三位骑士，而更像一个“第三轮”。
Witness a June 23rd article on the front page of the Wall Street Journal, titled "SEC Chief Under Fire As Fed Seeks Bigger Wall Street Role." The article starts off by describing a 5:00 AM conference call that took place in March between the country's top financial regulators. The topic of the phone call was what to do about the investment bank, Bear Stearns, which was about to collapse and possibly set in motion a global financial meltdown.
见证6月23日《华尔街日报》头版上的一篇文章，标题为“美联储寻求更大的华尔街角色，SEC主管遭炮轰”。这篇文章以描述3月份国家顶级金融监管机构之间一次凌晨5点的电话会议开头。电话会议的主题是关于如何处理投资银行贝尔斯登（Bear Stearns），该公司即将倒闭，并可能引发全球金融崩盘。
The article describes the events after the phone call this way, quote, "When they were done, the Treasury Secretary informed the President. The head of the Federal Reserve Bank of New York called Bear Stearns. Christopher Cox, Chairman of the Securities and Exchange Commission, didn't call anyone." Though the SEC was Bear Stearns regulator, he didn't take part in the meeting. In an interview, Mr. Cox said, the time of the call changed overnight and no one told him.
文章这样描述电话会议后的事件，引文：“当他们结束时，财政部长通知了总统。纽约联邦储备银行的行长给贝尔斯登打了电话。克里斯托弗·考克斯，证券交易委员会主席，没给任何人打电话。”尽管SEC是贝尔斯登的监管机构，但他没有参加会议。在一次采访中，考克斯先生说，电话会议的时间在一夜之间更改了，没人告诉他。
The article goes on to describe how the next night Cox missed the negotiations over what to do with Bear Stearns because he was at a birthday party. And how the day after that, he missed another conference call announcing the sale of Bear Stearns. The following weekend, he left town on a family vacation.
文章接着描述了考克斯如何在第二天晚上错过了关于如何处理贝尔斯登的谈判，因为他在参加一个生日派对。以及第二天之后，他错过了宣布出售贝尔斯登的另一次电话会议。随后的周末，他出城去进行家庭度假了。
So this was the backdrop in July, when the various crises gripping Wall Street and the nation's financial system suddenly took yet another turn for the worse. And Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac entered the stage for the first time.
所以这就是7月份的背景，当时困扰华尔街和国家金融体系的各种危机突然又恶化了。房利美和房地美第一次登上了舞台。
Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac, despite having names that a child might give to a puppy, are-- well, were-- two of the most important financial institutions in the American economy. They are involved in roughly 70% of the mortgages issued in the US today. If they collapsed, the housing market would come to an effective standstill, which is why, rather than let that happen, the government took them over last weekend.
房利美和房地美，尽管名字听起来像孩子给小狗起的名字，是——好吧，曾经是——美国经济中最重要的两家金融机构。它们今天参与了美国大约70%的抵押贷款发放。如果它们倒闭，住房市场实际上就会陷入停滞，这就是为什么与其让这种情况发生，政府在上周末接管了它们。
But back in July, when this story takes place, the failure of Fannie and Freddie had just started to seem like a possibility. Their stock price was tanking, had lost over 60% of its value in just one week. And so the government was trying to figure out what to do.
但在7月份，当这个故事发生时，房利美和房地美的倒闭才刚刚开始显得有可能。它们的股价在暴跌，一周内价值就损失了超过60%。所以政府在努力想办法该做什么。
Chairman Cox.
考克斯主席。
Thank you very much, Mr. Chairman, Senator Shelby and members of the committee for this opportunity to describe the SEC's actions to deal with the recent developments in our financial markets.
非常感谢，主席先生，谢尔比参议员以及委员会成员，感谢这次机会来描述SEC为处理我们金融市场最近的事态发展所采取的行动。
This is Chairman Cox testifying before the Senate Committee on Banking, Housing and Urban Affairs. Now, at this meeting, he's announcing his very first emergency action of this entire economic crisis. In fact, it's the only emergency action he's taken as SEC chairman. It's his first and boldest step onto the national stage as an enforcer. On this day, he's announcing an order aimed at stopping a particular Wall Street practice, a practice with a provocative name.
这是考克斯主席在参议院银行、住房和城市事务委员会作证。现在，在这次会议上，他正在宣布他在这场整个经济危机中的第一次紧急行动。事实上，这是他作为SEC主席所采取的唯一一次紧急行动。这是他作为执法者登上国家舞台的第一步，也是最大胆的一步。在这一天，他宣布了一项旨在制止特定华尔街做法的命令，一种名字听起来很有挑衅意味的做法。
Today the commission will issue an order designed to enhance protections against naked short selling in the securities of Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac.
今天，委员会将发布一项命令，旨在加强对房利美和房地美证券的“裸卖空”行为的保护。
You probably don't know what naked short selling is. I certainly didn't. And to understand it, you have to understand its upstanding cousin, regular short selling. Now, regular short selling is perfectly legal and incredibly common. It's just a way of making money if you think a stock price is about to go down in value.
你可能不知道什么是“裸卖空”。我肯定不知道。要理解它，你必须理解它那位受人尊敬的堂兄——常规卖空。常规卖空完全合法且非常普遍。如果你认为股票价格即将下跌，这只是一种赚钱的方法。
Here's how it works. Say I think IBM is headed for a fall. I find someone who owns a whole bunch of IBM stock, and I say to that person, can I borrow 1,000 shares. The person says, fine, and lends me the shares, which I immediately sell on the market. Later, maybe a couple of hours or days or weeks, I go back on the market, buy back the 1,000 shares of IBM and return them to my lender.
运作方式是这样的。假设我认为IBM公司注定要下跌。我找到一个拥有大量IBM股票的人，我对那个人说，能借给我1000股吗？那个人说，好的，把股票借给我，我立即在市场上卖掉。后来，也许几个小时、几天或几周后，我回到市场，买回1000股IBM股票并还给我的出借人。
If I'm right and the stock has gone down, then I've made money. I sold for, say, $10 a share, but bought back at $5 a share. I pay the lender a small fee and I get to keep the difference. It's pretty straightforward, and happens millions of times a day on Wall Street.
如果我是对的，股票确实下跌了，那么我就赚了钱。比如我以每股10美元卖出，却以每股5美元买回。我付给借款人一小笔费用，剩下的差价归我。这非常简单，在华尔街每天发生数百万次。
It gets confusing, as things so often do, when you get to the naked part. Everyone I talked to initially about this story explained it to me this way. Naked short selling, they said, is the same as regular short selling, except that you don't actually borrow the stock first. But that doesn't make any sense. How can I sell something that I haven't borrowed?
就像事情经常发生的那样，一旦到了“裸”的那部分，就变得令人困惑了。我和每一个最初谈论这个故事的人都以这种方式向我解释。他们说，裸卖空和常规卖空是一样的，区别在于你并没有真正先借入股票。但这根本讲不通。我还没借的东西怎么卖呢？
My name is Jim Coffman. I'm retired from the Securities and Exchange Commission. I used to run investigations in the enforcement division there.
我的名字是吉姆·考夫曼（Jim Coffman）。我从证券交易委员会退休了。我曾经在那里负责执法部门的调查。
And how long did you work there?
你在那里工作了多久？
26, almost 27 years.
26年，快27年了。
OK. This is the thing that I think that's hard for civilians to understand, is when you short sell, you borrow the stock from somebody, you sell it at the current price, you wait for the price to go down, you buy it back, and then you give the stock back to who you borrowed it from. When you naked short sell, you haven't borrowed the stock yet.
好的。这是我认为平民很难理解的事情，当你卖空时，你向某人借入股票，按当前价格卖出，等待价格下跌，再买回来，然后把股票还给借给你的人。当你“裸卖空”时，你还没有借入股票。
That's right.
没错。
What are you selling?
你在卖什么？
You're selling the stock.
你在卖股票。
But you don't have the stock.
但你没有股票。
It doesn't matter. It would be no different, in many respects, than selling a car that you don't own. You get the money, you put it in your pocket, and you don't deliver the car. In some circumstances that would be considered-- that is, selling an item you don't own would be considered a criminal activity. That's not true in the stock market.
没关系。在许多方面，这和你卖掉一辆你不拥有的汽车没什么区别。你拿到了钱，放进你的口袋，却不交付汽车。在某些情况下，那会被视为——也就是说，卖掉你没有的东西会被视为犯罪活动。在股市里并非如此。
And why is that not true in the stock market?
为什么在股市里并非如此呢？
Uh. To paraphrase a presidential candidate, that's not in my pay grade.
呃。借用一位总统候选人的话来说，那不在我的薪资等级范围内。
It turns out that naked short selling is one of those crazy corners of the financial system that when you come upon it for the first time, you can't believe it actually works that way.
事实证明，裸卖空是金融系统里那些疯狂角落之一，当你第一次遇到它时，你简直不敢相信它是那样运作的。
The whole thing started back when stocks were actual paper slips that stock boys ran back and forth across Wall Street in wheelbarrows. In those days, if I called my broker and I said I wanted to short a stock, my broker would pour himself a scotch and say, I see, old man, have you borrowed it yet? And I'd say, no, not yet, but when I do, I'll have my boy run it over in a wheelbarrow. And then my broker would say, well, fine then, old chap. I'll go ahead and sell it.
整个事情开始于股票还是真正的纸质凭证的年代，那时股票小弟用独轮车在华尔街跑来跑去。在那个年代，如果我打电话给我的经纪人，说我想卖空一只股票，我的经纪人会给自己倒上一杯苏格兰威士忌，说，我明白了，老兄，你借到了吗？我会说，还没，但当我借到时，我会让我手下用独轮车送过去。然后我的经纪人会说，好吧，老伙计。我会去卖掉它。
Despite the fact that everything is done on computer today, that old system is still more or less in place, meaning it's still possible to call my broker and have him sell shares that I don't own and haven't borrowed and have the money still show up in my account. And whoever bought the phantom shares I sold has those shares credited to their account. Then something called the clearing and settlement system gets stuck with the headache of following up on it all.
尽管今天一切都在电脑上完成，但那个旧系统或多或少还在原地，意味着我仍然可以打电话给我的经纪人，让他卖掉我不拥有、也没借入的股票，钱还是会显示在我的账户里。而任何买了被我卖掉的幻影股票的人，他们的账户里会有这些股票的入账。然后，所谓的清算和结算系统就被留下了处理这一切的头疼问题。
If the shares that I sold continue not to show up for three days, the settlement and clearing system declares what's called a fail to deliver. The buyer still owns the stock that never really existed, and I still keep the money from the sale of the stock that never really existed. The only one who's harangued is my broker.
如果我卖掉的股票在三天内没有出现，结算和清算系统就会宣布所谓的“交付失败”。买家仍然拥有从未真正存在的股票，而我仍然保留着卖掉从未真正存在的股票所赚的钱。唯一被骚扰的是我的经纪人。
The clearing agent contacts the seller's broker and says, you have a fail here, and tells them that, you know, they need to settle that up in x number of days. I think it's 13 days or something like that. The broker may or may not do that.
清算代理联系卖方的经纪人说，这里有一次失败，并告诉他们，你知道，他们需要在X天内解决这个问题。我想是13天还是什么的。经纪人可能会也可能不会那么做。
If the broker doesn't do that, they'll continue to get nasty calls and nasty letters, but that's about the size of it. And some brokers, depending on the nature of the broker and depending on the importance of the customer who has sold the shares short to that broker, may or may not bother to obtain shares and deliver them out.
如果经纪人没那么做，他们会继续接到讨人厌的电话和讨厌的信件，但规模也就到此为止了。一些经纪人，取决于经纪人的性质和卖空股票的客户对经纪人的重要性，可能会也可能不会费心去获取股票并交付出去。
Here's the thing, though. Most fails, the vast majority, eventually do clear, and the ones that don't are just a tiny fraction of the total market, where over a billion shares can trade every day. In the 20-plus years that Jim Coffman worked at the SEC, he did investigate and even bring enforcement actions against naked short sellers. But it was for the most part, he says, a fringe activity that took place in the markets murkier corners. To Jim Coffman, the notion that naked short selling by itself could bring down multi-billion dollar companies, like Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac, just doesn't make sense.
不过重点是，大多数失败，绝大多数，最终都会结算，而没结算的只是总市场的一小部分，总市场每天可以交易超过十亿股股票。在吉姆·考夫曼在SEC工作的20多年里，他确实调查甚至对裸卖空者采取了执法行动。但他表示，在很大程度上，这是一个发生在市场更阴暗角落的边缘活动。对吉姆·考夫曼来说，裸卖空本身就能摧毁像房利美和房地美这样几十亿美元的公司，根本讲不通。
Was there naked short selling in those entities? I have little doubt that there probably was, but it was far, far, far from being the primary cause for the decline in the prices of those securities.
那些实体里有裸卖空吗？我几乎不怀疑可能确实有，但它距离成为这些证券价格下跌的主要原因还差得远、远、远呢。
And so it was mystifying to Jim Coffman and all sorts of people who follow the SEC that several days after testifying on Capitol Hill, Chairman Cox made good on the promise to go after naked short selling, and came out with his promised emergency order preventing it.
所以，让吉姆·考夫曼和所有追踪SEC的人感到神秘的是，在国会山作证几天后，考克斯主席兑现了去对付裸卖空的承诺，并发布了他承诺的预防裸卖空的紧急命令。
The emergency order was unusual, because instead of banning naked short selling across the board, Cox outlawed the practice only when it came to the stock of 19 specific companies, which he listed in the order. There's Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac and 17 banks and brokerages, like Merrill Lynch and Goldman Sachs and Morgan Stanley and a bunch of other big names on Wall Street. And it was only a temporary ban lasting less than a month.
这项紧急命令很不寻常，因为考克斯没有在全市场范围内禁止裸卖空，而是只在涉及到19家特定公司时才禁止了这种做法，他在命令中列出了这些公司。其中包括房利美、房地美以及17家银行和经纪公司，比如美林证券、高盛、摩根士丹利以及华尔街的一堆其他大名。而且这只是一个为期不到一个月的临时禁令。
Lynn Turner was a chief accountant at the SEC for over 25 years. He's retired now, but he recalls how mystified he was when he heard about the order for the first time.
琳恩·特纳（Lynn Turner）在SEC担任总会计师超过25年。他现在退休了，但他记得第一次听到这个命令时他是多么困惑。
I recall it because I was actually over in Utah fly fishing with a bunch of other people who had been at the SEC, and I think we were all somewhat amazed by the whole situation. But certainly, it was talked a lot around the dinner table.
我记得是因为我当时正在犹他州和一群也在SEC待过的人飞钓，我想我们所有人都对整个情况感到有些惊讶。但可以肯定的是，在餐桌上谈论了很多。
It seemed to be strange that the SEC would be taking this particular path to trying to deal with the subprime crisis, when obviously there were other bigger issues out there. The SEC was just dealing with what seemed to be almost a sideshow of naked short selling.
SEC似乎在试图应对次贷危机时走上了这条特定的路径，这很奇怪，当时显然还有其他更大的问题。SEC只是在处理看起来几乎是裸卖空的“侧面戏”。
First of all, says Lynn, naked short selling was already basically illegal. A regulation passed in 2004 by the SEC required brokers to have a commitment to borrow shares before they sold them on the market.
首先，琳恩说，裸卖空基本上已经是违法的了。SEC在2004年通过的一项法规要求经纪人在市场上卖出股票之前必须有借入股票的承诺。
In addition, the SEC had the power to investigate all those fails to deliver. They could track down the people who didn't deliver the stock and prosecute them under existing law. And if you really wanted to further tighten regulations, there were much better ways of going about it.
此外，SEC有权调查所有这些交付失败。他们可以追踪那些没有交付股票的人，并根据现行法律起诉他们。如果你真的想进一步收紧法规，还有更好的方式。
You could simply adopt a rule here that said, on the date you sell these shares short, you've got to deliver the shares, just like when you buy shares, someone has to deliver to you on that day when you go long. It is a very simple, common sense fix. And I see no reason that the SEC couldn't do it, and I think it's a lot better than all of a sudden trying to come out with exemptive orders that apply to just 19 companies.
你可以简单地在那儿通过一条规则，规定：在你卖空这些股票的当天，你就必须交付股票，就像当你买入股票时，当你做多时，有人必须在那天交付给你。这是一个非常简单的、常识性的修复。我看不到SEC不能这样做的理由，我认为这比突然试图发布仅适用于19家公司的豁免命令要好得多。
And this was the strangest thing of all. If naked short selling is bad, then presumably it's bad for everyone. Why protect just 19 companies while leaving the rest of the corporate world exposed to this alleged danger?
而这是最奇怪的事情。如果裸卖空是坏事，那么大概它对每个人都是坏事。为什么要仅仅保护19家公司，而让其他公司世界暴露在这种所谓的危险中呢？
The SEC wouldn't talk to me for this story. They directed me to an op-ed that Chairman Cox had written, trying to explain his actions to a confused and skeptical public. In it he writes this, quote "The emergency order is not a response to unbridled naked short selling, which so far has not occurred. Rather, it is intended as a preventative step to help restore market confidence at a time when that is sorely needed."
SEC不会接受我对这个故事的采访。他们引导我去看考克斯主席写的一篇专栏文章，试图向困惑和怀疑的公众解释他的行为。他在文章中写道：“该紧急命令并不是对肆无忌惮的裸卖空的回应，到目前为止这种情况还没发生。相反，它旨在作为一种预防措施，以帮助在市场信心极度需要时恢复市场信心。”
In other words, he singled out 19 companies for protection from an already illegal practice that hadn't actually happened. How that's supposed to protect market confidence, he doesn't explain. Here's Lynn Turner.
换句话说，他挑选了19家公司来保护免受一种已经非法但实际上还没发生的行为的影响。那怎么能保护市场信心，他没解释。这是琳恩·特纳的观点。
You've just got to wonder whether-- you know, what was the real motive here? And I think the real motive was not so much to protect the markets, and not so much to protect the average investor, but to protect particular companies. And when you've got the regulator trying to protect particular companies and deciding who can or who cannot trade, that's no longer a free market.
你只是得怀疑——你知道，这里真正的动机是什么？我认为真正的动机与其说是保护市场，与其说是保护普通投资者，不如说是保护特定的公司。而当你让监管机构试图保护特定的公司并决定谁能或谁不能交易时，那就不再是自由市场了。
There's another way of looking at all of this, the way, presumably, Christopher Cox is looking at it, that this is, in fact, just the help the free market needs. This is an extraordinary time, this argument goes, and it calls for extraordinary measures. These 19 companies are so central to the operation of the global financial system that they deserve special treatment. The stakes are too high to let them fail, and we can't trust the market to ensure that they won't.
看待所有这一切还有另一种方式，据推测，克里斯托弗·考克斯正在以这种方式看待它，即这实际上正是自由市场所需要的帮助。这个观点认为，这是一个非凡的时代，它需要非凡的措施。这19家公司在全球金融体系运作中如此核心，以至于它们值得特殊待遇。风险太高了，不能让它们失败，而我们不能信任市场来确保它们不会失败。
But the problem is that's totally inconsistent with Cox's philosophy up until this point. If Chairman Cox had wanted to step in with the power of government, the last couple of years have presented ample opportunities that arguably would have been much less intrusive and that would have had the added benefit of fixing some of the problems that got us here in the first place.
但问题是这与考克斯在此之前的哲学完全不一致。如果考克斯主席想要利用政府的力量介入，过去几年已经提供了充足的机会，这些机会可以说是侵入性更小，而且会有一个额外的好处，那就是修复了一些让我们陷入今天境地的根本问题。
For example, says Jim Coffman, the former SEC investigator, it's a basic principle of economics that the market works best when buyers and sellers have good information about what's being bought and sold. But because of accounting loopholes, companies can keep potentially damaging information off their balance sheets, hidden from investors.
例如，前SEC调查员吉姆·考夫曼说，经济学的一个基本原则是，当买家和卖家对买卖的东西有良好的信息时，市场运作得最好。但因为会计漏洞，公司可以将潜在的破坏性信息留在资产负债表之外，向投资者隐瞒。
And the fact is there wasn't accurate and complete information in the marketplace, because the SEC didn't require them to disclose that information. So instead of requiring the disclosure of information that would remove the uncertainty from the marketplace and make it much easier for people to price securities fairly, the commission banned naked short selling.
事实是市场上没有准确完整的信息，因为SEC没要求他们披露这些信息。所以，SEC没要求披露那些会消除市场不确定性并使人们更容易公平定价证券的信息，而是禁止了裸卖空。
Another issue, says former SEC Chief Accountant Lynn Turner, is the credit rating agencies. OK, again, a little explanation. Credit rating agencies, as their name suggests, rate things, bonds and securities and specifically for our story, a type of security called a CDO, which is the thing that set in motion this entire financial crisis.
前SEC总会计师琳恩·特纳说，另一个问题是信用评级机构。好的，再次说明一下。信用评级机构，顾名思义，给债券和证券评级，专门针对我们的故事，一类叫CDO的证券，这就是引发这场整个金融危机的东西。
Now, Wall Street created these CDOs, and it wanted the credit rating agencies to give them high ratings, in essence, to declare them safe for investors. The problem is, A, they weren't safe, and, B, the rating agencies were paid by the same Wall Street firms whose securities they were rating, a clear conflict of interest. So if a Wall Street firm doesn't like the rating one agency gives it, it can just switch to another agency.
现在，华尔街创造了这些CDO，并且希望信用评级机构给它们高评级，本质上就是向投资者宣布它们是安全的。问题是，A，它们并不安全，以及，B，评级机构是由它们评级的证券的同一家华尔街公司支付报酬的，存在明显的利益冲突。所以如果一家华尔街公司不喜欢某机构给的评级，它可以直接切换到另一家机构。
And during the housing bubble, when lots and lots of these securities were being created, there was a ton of money to be made, a huge incentive for the rating agencies to give high ratings. And the rating agencies were pulling in record amounts of money.
在房地产泡沫期间，当大量这些证券被创造出来时，有大笔钱可赚，评级机构有巨大的动力给出高评级。而评级机构正赚进创纪录的金额。
In a hearing-- I believe it was the spring time-- Chairman Cox from the SEC was questioned about that by Senator Shelby from Alabama and Senator Jack Reed from Rhode Island. And they asked the Chairman during the testimony, wouldn't he like to have legislation that would fix that and would give him the additional powers to be able to change those policies and procedures or demand changes in them when appropriate? And to that Chairman Cox responded, no.
在一次听证会上——我相信是在春季——SEC的考克斯主席被来自阿拉巴马州的谢尔比参议员和来自罗德岛州的杰克·里德（Jack Reed）参议员质问。他们在作证期间问主席，难道他不想要立法来修复这个问题，并给予他额外的权力以在适当的时候能够改变那些政策和程序，或要求对其进行更改吗？对此，考克斯主席回答，不。
I think the point that you do not feel the statute gives you the authority to examine the substance of the credit ratings or the procedures and methodologies, would you want that authority given the situation we've seen in the marketplace?
我想你觉得法规没给你审查信用评级实质或程序和方法的权力这一点，在鉴于我们在市场上所看到的情况，你想要赋予那种权力吗？
No, Mr. Chairman, at this juncture it's my judgment that you and the Congress have struck a sound balance.
不，主席先生，在现阶段我的判断是，你和国会已经达成了一种合理的平衡。
And I think it just basically astounded the two senators, and I think most people, if they were aware of that, would be astounded by it as well.
而我觉得这基本上让两位参议员感到震惊，我想大多数人如果知道这一点的话，也会感到震惊。
They were basically saying, we will write you whatever legislation you need to go after this problem.
他们基本上是在说，我们会为你写任何你需要去对付这个问题的立法。
Yes, that's exactly right.
是的，完全正确。
It seems to me, too, you have to have an interest that these agencies are consistently producing credit ratings with integrity. And how do you accomplish that unless you're able to go in and look at the substance of their procedures and methodologies?
在我看来，你也必须对这些机构始终如一地制作有诚信的信用评级感兴趣。如果不能进去看它们的程序和方法的实质，你如何实现这一点？
Well, as I say, I think that you and the Congress have struck the proper balance here, because--
嗯，就像我说的，我认为你和国会在这里达成了适当的平衡，因为……
Well, at least in terms of discussion, that's on the table.
嗯，至少在讨论方面，这已经在桌子上了。
Yes, of course.
是的，当然。
At another point during this hearing, Senator Reed asks Chairman Cox whether he needs more money for enforcement. Again, the chairman declines.
在这次听证会的另一个时间点，里德参议员问考克斯主席他是否需要更多的执法资金。主席再次拒绝了。
Do you feel, Mr. Chairman, that the amount that you're going to be given here is enough resources to effectively oversee the securities markets? And if not, would you share with the committee what you believe you're going to need?
你觉得，主席先生，你将被给予的数量是否有足够的资源来有效监督证券市场？如果没有，你会和委员会分享你认为你需要什么吗？
I think overall the nearly billion dollars that Congress has provided us in the latest budget is ample.
我认为总的来说，国会在最新预算中提供给我们的近十亿美元是充足的。
The ranking Republican on this committee, Richard Shelby, is a recipient of the Spirit of Enterprise Award from the US Chamber of Commerce, a man very easily described as a pro-business, anti-regulation conservative. But the current financial turmoil has made those old labels a little unreliable, which in turn has made things like Senate banking subcommittee hearings very odd affairs, where you can be treated to the strange spectacle of one pro-business Republican, Richard Shelby, arguing with another pro-business Republican, Christopher Cox, about the need for stronger regulation and enforcement of the markets. It's especially strange, because the one arguing against this regulation is the chief regulator. Here's Senator Shelby laying down the law.
这个委员会中排名最高的共和党人理查德·谢尔比，是美国商会“企业精神奖”的获得者，一个人很容易被描述为亲商业、反监管的保守派。但当前的金融动荡让那些旧标签变得有点不可靠了，这反过来让参议院银行小组委员会听证会之类的事情变得非常奇怪，在那里你可以体验到一种奇怪的奇观：一个亲商业的共和党人理查德·谢尔比，在与另一个亲商业的共和党人克里斯托弗·考克斯，争论市场需要更强有力的监管和执法。这尤其奇怪，因为那个反对这种监管的人恰恰是首席监管官。这是谢尔比参议员在下达命令。
I hope that you, in your leadership with the other commissioners, will do the job that needs to be done. We're at a crisis here. If the SEC's not going to do the job, somebody else will have to do the job.
我希望你，在你与其他委员的领导下，会去做需要做的工作。我们这里处于危机之中。如果SEC不去做这项工作，其他人就必须去做这项工作。
Christopher Cox, like a lot of people in government these days, has an ideological opposition to government regulation. The market, in his view, will correct itself. Credit rating agencies with bad ratings, for example, will eventually go out of business. Essentially, he trusts the market to get things right more than he trusts the government.
克里斯托弗·考克斯，就像这些天政府里的许多人一样，对政府监管持意识形态上的反对态度。在他看来，市场会自我修正。例如，评级糟糕的信用评级机构最终会倒闭。本质上，他信任市场能把事情做好，胜过他信任政府。
He holds that view almost across the board, except when it comes to 19 banks and brokerages on Wall Street. But in this case, he should have trusted his instincts, because the government intervention did indeed botch the job. When Cox's emergency order expired in mid-August, the stock prices for most of the companies he was trying to protect were actually lower than when the order first went into effect. And we all know what happened to Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac.
他在几乎所有领域都持有这种观点，除了涉及华尔街那19家银行和经纪公司时。但在这种情况下，他本应相信自己的直觉，因为政府干预确实搞砸了工作。当考克斯的紧急命令在8月中旬到期时，他试图保护的大多数公司的股价实际上比命令刚生效时还要低。而我们都知道房利美和房地美发生了什么。
Alex Blumberg. He's one of the producers of our program. His story is going to be on NPR'S new Planet Money podcast, which came about after our Global Pool of Money show, the show that Alex did on the mortgage crisis with NPR's Adam Davidson. They're doing a couple new stories a week in the spirit of that show, the Planet Money podcast. To find that, go to npr.org/money.
亚历克斯·布隆伯格。他是我们节目的制作人之一。他的故事将出现在NPR的新播客《行星货币》（Planet Money）上，这是在我们的《全球金钱池》（Global Pool of Money）节目之后出现的，那是亚历克斯与NPR的亚当·戴维森（Adam Davidson）一起做的关于抵押贷款危机的节目。他们正在本着那个节目的精神每周做几个新故事，即《行星货币》播客。要找到它，请访问npr.org/money。
This song, by the way, is called "I Go Chop Your Dollar," very popular, apparently, among some of the email scammers in Nigeria, which is where the song comes from.
顺便说一句，这首歌叫《我要榨干你的钱》（I Go Chop Your Dollar），显然在尼日利亚的一些电子邮件骗子中非常受欢迎，这首歌就来自那里。
Well, our show is produced today by Robyn Semien and Nancy Updike with Alex Blumberg, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollak, and Alissa Shipp. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Production help from Seth Lind and PJ Vogt. Music help from Jessica Hopper.
嗯，我们今天的节目由罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、简·费尔特斯（Jane Feltes）、萨拉·凯尼格（Sarah Koenig）、莉萨·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）和阿莉莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）参与。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。阿德里安娜·马西奥韦茨（Adrianne Mathiowetz）运营我们的网站。制作帮助来自塞思·林德（Seth Lind）和PJ沃格特（PJ Vogt）。音乐帮助来自杰西卡·霍珀（Jessica Hopper）。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Joe Kocur's book about life as a hockey enforcer is called The Bruise Brothers , available only at immortalinvestments.com.
乔·科库尔关于作为冰球执法者的生活的书叫《瘀伤兄弟》（The Bruise Brothers），仅在immortalinvestments.com有售。
To read the full, incredible day-by-day account of baiting Adamu with maps and photos and audio recordings, you can go to 419eater.com, or just follow the link from our website, www.thisamericanlife.org.
要阅读关于用地图、照片和录音诱饵亚当的完整、令人难以置信的逐日记录，你可以去419eater.com，或者直接点击我们网站www.thisamericanlife.org上的链接。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management over sight by our boss Mr. Torey Malatia. When we forgot to pick him up to go to the Emmy awards ceremony, where we are up for five, yes, five Emmys, he called to say,
WBEZ管理层由我们的老板托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）监督。当我们忘了去接他参加艾美奖颁奖典礼时，我们获得了五个，是的，五个艾美奖提名，他打电话过来说，
I've been trying to call this number for two hours. I'm in traffic right now. I am in traffic. I'm on my way back now. I'm leaving. And damn it, I'm crotchety.
我两小时来一直在打这个号码。我现在在交通拥堵中。我在拥堵中。我正在回去的路上。我要走了。该死的，我很暴躁。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。